let's head out to the newsroom now where
kevin martin is tracking reaction from
today's stunning news kevin
well thanks chris you know news broke
just about four hours ago ago around 6
p.m that john gruden was resigning as
the raiders head coach but we all know
we live in a time now that you can share
your thoughts on feelings on basically
anything almost immediately on social
media so as you can imagine the nfl
world in the world in general exploded
on twitter earlier here's some reactions
from around the nfl and other notable
names former all-pro-wide receiver dez
bryant tweeting john gruden crazy fellow
former nfl
wideout mike wallace saying gruden had
to go simple as that sportscaster jim
rome chiming in good riddance rg3
stating you can't be racist homophobic
and misogynistic you shouldn't be any of
them shannon sharp saying mark davis did
the right thing and bill barneau echoing
rome and saying good riddance the
governor of nevada steve sisilak also
chimed in saying this kind of behavior
is unacceptable and reprehensible las
vegas is a welcoming city and the
raiders are part of our family there's
no place for hate here a lot of strong
reactions from some notable names but as
far as the play on the field the team
has to get refocused somehow as a huge
divisional game awaits this weekend in
denver against the broncos reporting
live in the newsroom kevin martin brian
back to you kevin thank you local
advocates who just celebrated pride last
weekend say seeing these comments is
proof that more educating needs to
happen
this is the reason why it's hard for
lgbtq athletes to either come out even
want to engage in sports at that level
because they already know like what's on
the other side
the henderson equality center sharing a
statement it is very upsetting that in
this day and age people can still be so
hateful towards each other every time we
move steps ahead hate like today brings
us back
now chris matthews will have more on
this developing story coming up in
sports but when we're not on air you can
find updates on our social media handles
and on eight newsnow dot com